hi guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you as more twists and
turns to this Kajima story than a metal
gear game as konami has announced that
they're in the planning stages of a new
one despite the fact that Kajima might
not be there anymore the corporation
added that it is conducting auditions
for main staff to lead the development
and does that interested developers to
get in touch sources from within the
studio revealed that hideo kojima who
has spearheaded the Metal Gear franchise
at Konami for nearly 30 years is
expected to leave Kojima Productions in
December following the release of metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain the
publisher has not commented on this
matter specifically but instead has
issued a statement assuring that it will
continue to work on the franchise Konami
will continue to develop and distribute
top quality content in the Metal Gear
series following metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain we greatly anticipate and
deeply appreciate your ongoing support
for Metal Gear it's added as the next
step in the series konami has already
resolved to develop a new Metal Gear
title we will be conducting auditions
for main staff to lead the development
interested parties are encouraged to
contact us via the recruitment page of
the Konami official website so what do
you make of it all are you interested in
playing another metal gear game not
helmed by kojima is this all the work of
the Philosopher's if you don't know who
the Philosopher's are and you want to
get to grips with Metal Gear storyline
then why not check out my in two minutes
two-parter before I go through the whole
thing you can check that out here on
gamespot com